all right everybody hopefully this is
work ah there we are so we're kicking
off this one it's it's not my birthday
yet birthday's in two days but it's
pretty close and yeah I received some
more stuff which is always fun so we're
gonna kick off in style and good evening
to you as well because I solemnly swear
that I am up to no good
did you just have a little bit of liquid
luck yes for once it's not water all
right Cheers
so I think we're gonna get into Oh
Hufflepuff from Maryland very nice happy
almost birthday I'll take it I did see
senator say it is somebody in the chat
actual birthday so happy birthday to
that person we're drinking together oh
that's nice Sophie I appreciate that
Australia boy all over the place so yeah
I'm gonna kind of kick things off right
off the bat cuz I got a whole bunch of
assumptions from people most of them
came in on the community post on the
YouTube channel I've got some in from
Twitter as well so yeah no there's one
other thing I'm gonna mention before and
I'll have a reminder um a little bit
later in the week but I know I'm
shameless but my book skirting gender is
actually going to I was gonna say it's
gonna go on sale it's actually if you
have Kindle unlimited it's going to be
free from the 21st which is my birthday
which is the reason I'm doing
through the 26 that's five days that
this will actually be free on on Kindle
unlimited if you have that so if you
have not checked the book out if you
have any interest at all I would
encourage you to do so maybe give it a
review if you have read it okay not for
my self promotion moving on from that uh
I'm drinking cider almost finished so
get another cider man come on
is it cold where you live not sure if
that's to me or someone in the chat yeah
I live in Vermont so right now it's it's
in that weird wavering point because
like in the morning it'll be like ten
degrees but then during the day I'll get
up close to 40 so like it starts to melt
during the day but then it freezes at
night it's it's spring almost spring
anyway so some of the assumptions that
folks sent in and I'll start addressing
them it'll pause and I'll you know I'll
try and keep one eye on the chat but I
also got other stuff that people sent me
for my birthday that'll probably bring
up as we go along but let's do this so
first one I've got up here you get
really swept up when reading bedtime
stories to your kid and do all the
voices yeah yeah that one's super
accurate that's actually I've really
been enjoying she's gotten into the bun
aquila books if you ever read those
those are great for being super
overdramatic about because there's
they're they're deliberately written to
be over-the-top so yeah yeah I
definitely do that uh she's the
buffering street oh dear
people just testing I had to reload all
right sounds like some people got a
reload but yeah stick with me if you can
and I'm keeping an eye on it from my end
it's looking like it's so working oh
doctor who guide hey there ah next one
up what I had you were one of the weird
theater kids in high school
yeah yeah I like I've got I've got no
counter no caveat no asterisk to put on
that like yeah yeah yeah yeah was not
only in high school that continued for I
would actually argue that I'm still a
weird theatre kid uh I assume you have a
hat collection but you only wear the one
for branding purposes I'm not sure it's
enough to call it a collection but I say
that as I glance over and see the five
that are up there and I can see the two
that are in my closet cuz the closet
doors open so like I don't know how many
you have to have to qualify it as a
collection but yeah I do have more than
just the one hat but yeah it is it is
kind of a branding thing at this point
yeah nothing better than a good refresh
oh good it's working
is there any doctor who creepypastas I
hope not creepypastas not really my my
thing you want every sonic screwdriver I
have every sonic screwdriver so I
already did that one next up for an
assumption you're into musicals um yeah
I mean I'm not like a complete nut on
them but ya know I enjoy I enjoy a good
musical I assume you're a good parent
god I hope so
I'll probably find out in about Oh
probably about 1213 years or so when
she's old enough to feel emboldened to
tell me to my face how much I screwed
her up and like and put some thought
into it so uh we'll see that you like
cats I'm assuming they mean the animal
as opposed to the terrible Broadway
musical um I do I do like cats
i alternate lee and i think this came up
in other questions as well so I'll try
and avoid repeaters I I am a little bit
more of a dog person than a cat person
but I do like cats I've had cats are you
a fan of John Locke
I mean I'm not a shipper so I mean in
different Doctor Who and the Pirates is
based on a musical part three mostly
yeah like a bunch of people have been
mentioning that lately the the Doctor
Who and the Pirates I need to look into
into that whatever's going on there what
are you oh dear okay uh I was debating
whether or not to bring this up but
somebody just asked in the chat what are
your thoughts on the Toy Story 4 trailer
I'm not gonna devote a video to this um
but I hate it like every second of it I
hate it like I I'm toy story isn't as
much a part of my childhood as it seems
to be for a lot of people my age who are
just like going oh and it touches them
in their heart and I'm not trying to
take that away from anybody but because
it doesn't hit my chop my inner child as
hard I look at this and go there is
nothing here that the series hasn't
already done before so you're going to
continue after a really excellent
closure to the story and just revisit
the same crap and I also I mentioned
this on Twitter so anyone who calls me
on day on there might have already heard
it but Bo Bo Peep most of the stuff that
she's saying is the same stuff the
villains of the last two movies were
saying so right now I'm giving even odds
on Bo Peep being the secret surprise
villian of Toy Story 4 and and I don't
know how strongly I believe that but I
want it on record so if it happens I can
say I've freaking called it yeah moving
on what pronouns do you use whatever
makes sense in your head that's that's
that's the short answer
alright what else we get your favorite
of the queer eye cast is Bobbie I have
not seen the new queer eye so no but not
because someone else is my favorite but
because I don't know you're smart and
funny I'm not gonna respond to that cuz
that's for you
guys to decide love sci-fi oh and
wouldn't always be particularly
predictable I actually think that I'm
not all that unpredictable I'm just kind
of protective of like the information
you need to be able to predict me if
that makes sense like people who know me
well like my partner Liz for example my
daughter's mother you know some of my
really close friends they actually they
they've got my number completely like
they they they can predict me you know
like like nobody's business but it's
because like they know enough about me
and I've kind of open up and out of
enough to them that they know all the
variables so I'm probably unpredictable
to a lot of people from the outside
looking in though Doctor Who Loved and
monsters is secretly a guilty pleasure
pleasure of yours no no just no oh God
when's the next 90s comics free trial I
don't know I didn't even know what issue
I'm gonna do next so probably not for a
little while you work in a computer
science or computer graphics based field
that new I dunno I don't talk about my
job and I'm not going to here because
it's it's not interesting and it's the
kind of details that I do like to
pervert a keep to myself but no no and
actually like computer software hates me
I've said in the past technology hates
me it is really specifically software
because straight mechanical that doesn't
screw with me software hates me
cuz it always fails in a way that's like
it's never supposed to fail like I'll
have something there go oh well this is
kind of hiccupping a little I like try
and google it or whatever and like
nobody has ever heard of the problem I'm
having and that happens to me a lot you
you like LARPing um I haven't LARP done
a long time but back in the day I used
to do
vampire the masquerade as a LARP and if
you don't know what any of those words
mean that's probably better for my image
and I'm kind of counting on the fact
that anyone who does know what those
words that just came out of my mouth
mean that they're just as huge dorks as
I am so they can't judge me
who was your favorite buff evil not what
I'm not gonna answer because eventually
I'm gonna do a villain countdown with
Liz and I don't want to I don't want to
give it away let's see you were the one
kid who got way too into character while
reading a novel and literature class yes
and no I was but there wasn't just one
there were like five of us but I yeah I
was I was that you have often had to
turn on geeky TV shows you love because
your kid has started getting bored or
Restless uh no because I did a video on
this my kid does not share my geeky
fandom so if I if she's bored I can't
put on something I like uh occupier have
you seen the vampire there's a vampire
the masquerade makeup line no no I have
not seen that but I'm now immediately
curious any opinion on love Simon no
because I haven't seen it you are not
critical in real life and use videos to
get your egg ravais ssin cynical side
out not true that thinking that I do of
zeroing in on either what the problems
are or what the problems might be in the
case is something like a trailer
something's not even out yet I do that
in life that's it's actually just kind
of a thing that I do and I wish I could
turn off but I kind of can so what can
you do
you are human yes
you have good manners most of the time I
try to I'm not sure how consistent I am
on that but I try to you Drock being
part of an improv group I'm not as great
at improv as as you might think
although I haven't done it in a long
time then again like I say that but part
of it might be that like I was friends
with people who were way better at it
than I was so see the game queue at the
back to you game at all not much these
days I don't have time I'm doing
anything current-gen um do you have
training for the weapons on your wall no
huh no I don't I've got a bo staff off
in the corner over there that I actually
know how to use nothing up here do I
have a clue how to use properly that
you're super understanding again I try
to be I again don't know how often I
nail that this is what I found
interesting cuz I actually I I tend to
think this is assumption a lot of people
probably do make so I kind of like that
this one got got brought up you're an
atheist actually I'm not um like I'm not
I can't like just stick a label on
things I'm not I wasn't raised as
anything I don't go to church I don't
practice or take stock in any formalized
religion but I'm not an atheist I I
actually do believe in God I have zero
concept of the nature and you know wants
or desires and guiding principles of God
but I do still believe so I guess I
think of it as kind of a spiritual
agnosticism mmm-hmm you love Ren fairs
yes I do super accurate favorite Ninja
Turtle Raphael Raphael has always been
my dude you are pansexual but mostly
interested in women um like I would I
would switch that out for mostly to like
borderline exclusively but yeah actually
that's accurate
you think you have way too many
steampunk novels and yet feel like you
don't have enough I've actually never
read a steampunk novel like I like
steampunk as a as an aesthetic as a look
um but so like I like the fashion I like
the outfits I've never read a steampunk
steampunk book though so just a generic
theist yeah yes I suppose least favorite
companion Clara well I mean it depends
if we're talking modern whoo modern whoo
yes but if they don't get yaz to have a
point soon Clara might have somebody
taking that title
who's this Jenny gender sort of stealing
your stick I'm not sure if that's a joke
or not I don't know let's see what else
have I got
you thought let's kill Hitler was a
mediocre episode I mean I haven't gotten
to it yet on the revisit um I've got a
little ways to go before I get there but
my memory of let's kill Hitler was I
thought it was pretty fun I mean we'll
sit we'll see if it stays that way
will you ever read scratch Minh I don't
know I mean I would like to say yes but
like I there's so much I want to do and
see and read and like I I just don't
know um okay so more some it's a cat
person dog person thing I kind of
addressed that I after 20 months of
being subscribed to you I don't think
I've heard you sing until that one
previous video that being said I assume
you're great when it comes to big to
video ki night actually like I I have a
pretty not high opinion of my own
singing Billy but it's a little bit like
what I said with my ability to do improv
which is that I'm friends with people
who are legitimately great
like one of my really close friends is
like is a choir director
so like music and singing is part of her
job and I've got friends in bands and I
I've got a co-worker who's who's a
musician on the side and like they're
all good they're not like oh you know
garage but no they're actually good so
my my notion of how good of a singer I
am is is probably lower than the reality
but I'm certainly not cocky about it
managed to catch another stream nice to
see you there ace even though you
already viewed series eight nine ten
would you eventually revisit after a few
years and do a series overview I don't
know because like I'll buy about mid I
think next year I will have caught up to
where I started doing video reviews for
Doctor Who and then the question is
whether I replace the overdue Doctor Who
reviews with like take to Doctor Who
reviews and basically do second videos
because it'll have been a few years
since that stop I don't know if I'm
gonna do that or not and I've got like a
year plus to decide whether or not I'm
gonna do that so we shall see doctor who
is your favorite fandom yeah yeah you
you you got that one you are very humble
no I am NOT I try I try not to be a jerk
but like I've I've got an ego I've got a
pretty substantial ego um I'm gonna jump
over to Twitter and see what I can pull
from there um you believe anything worth
doing is worth overdoing
um selectively like performance I'll
overdo it you know to heck but there
there's a lot in my life that I just I'm
just kind of like you know that this is
worth doing but I also need to just get
some version of it done and move on so
like sort of the Oh God okay this one's
from Twitter
huh I assume that x-men that x-men's
executioner song is your favorite comic
story of all the time and since you
covered it already you don't bother
podcasting about any other comic stories
because everything else pales in quality
to that masterpiece Kyle I hate you all
right anyone who hasn't listened to the
90s comics retrial podcast backlog which
i assume is most people wouldn't know
this but covering executioner song is
the reason I stopped doing that podcast
cuz it broke me it was oh god it it hurt
a lot and Kyle knew that ah let's see
what else you haven't watched all of
classic who but you but you know a ton
about it due to intensive research no I
know a fair amount about it due to
casual research so like I've been
following Doctor Who in like bringing up
a wikipedia or a fan whatever
sporadically enough that yeah I've
caught on to a fair amount of stuff that
that's from have stories I haven't seen
but it's not intensive research thank
you for watching anyone watched a recent
release of Shara and I have not gotten
to that one yet we'll see
I love the new profile a photo on
Twitter yeah I did I did swap out the
the avatar on Twitter recently like nice
for a change of pace that on one
platform you sing a lot when you are by
yourself actually no I dance a lot when
I'm by myself
I assume you're an extrovert
kind of not across the board the thing
is like I can be if I'm in an
environment where like I'm comfortable
so like if if I'm going somewhere where
like I've been there before and I know
who's gonna be there or at least I know
that the P
or gonna be there yo will be happy to
see me so like a performance venues a
good example yeah I can be quite
extroverted but like I get I get really
mm uncomfortable whenever I have to go
to some place that I've never been to
before and or it's gonna be populated
largely by people I don't know I can get
a little bit sort of off in the corner
in the in those situations so I I don't
I don't go into a shell often but it
does happen from time to time this is a
question not an assumption do you think
doctor who works better being dark
serious emotional or funny it needs it
needs to do all those things that is the
beauty of Doctor Who if it ever started
doing only one of those things all the
time it would not be the show that it is
so most of my favorite episodes are on
the more serious end but no it needs all
of them you like Christmas yes I don't
like how early they start playing
Christmas music on the radio but yes I
do I do like the holiday itself you
prefer new who to classic ooh that's
still true even though at this point on
paper I think there is more to like for
my taste in classic who then new it's
still you know it's still cheesy
production values and there's only so
much I can get over that I think that's
why I like Big Finish so much cuz most
of my favorite Big Finish is a little
bit more reminiscent of classic whoo
than it is of new whoo but I'm not
burdened with terrible production value
because I don't have to see it so you
can play piano I can't play anything so
that's uh that's a big swing in a miss
you don't really like cake no I do I
likes cake I assume you are concept you
are accepting of conservative ideology
but surround yourself with those who
aren't um sort of they only think that
I'll contend with is that the
the wording on that makes it seem like
it's by design that I'm largely
surrounded by more liberally minded
people but that's just more like those
though the people who I have met through
the interest that I have have been that
so yes I try to be accepting most of my
friends are liberal again not by intent
but it has happened that way that you're
non-binary or genderqueer
I mean I usually go with gender fluid
because most people when they say
non-binary or genderqueer they like have
a fixed sense of gender it's just not on
either ends of the binary male/female
spectrum whereas I use gender fluid
because like I'm all over the place day
to day dr. Frank Frank converters your
favorite character from from the Rocky
Horror Picture Show
I actually think riff raff might be my
favorite um Frank's right up there
though how often do you do unboxing
videos I really don't like I've only
done them I think twice once as a
patreon video and then once I think for
the holidays here it's just I if I if I
had more restraint about um you know the
stuff that has been showing up related
to my birthday I would have done an
unboxing video around that stuff but I'm
impatient can't wait and I want to see
you now and I'm too lazy to cut together
footage of me opening up on like all
these different days so uh maybe next
year I'll I'll think about it you go you
go to hairdressers only like twice a
year to lighten your roots no I go to
hairdressers at least once a month to to
clean this up and then you know I'm long
overdue to get to get to get a recolor
but I haven't had the time you've never
had the chance to eat a durian no and
because of what I know about what that
what durians tastes like I don't have
any plans do find myself in a situation
where I might eat a durian I watch or I
used to watch Food Network often enough
that durians would come up in like
competition shows and I'm like Oh God ha
ha ha so for anyone who doesn't know is
basically a fruit that smells and tastes
like white garbage
Raptors scare the crap out of you um no
actually they don't I even when I was a
kid the Raptors never scared me I always
just thought that they were cool ah
let's see
you know ok we're nearing the halfway
mark so I'm actually gonna pause and
since I'd like it's not quite an
unboxing but some of the other stuff
that has arrived since the last
livestream unrelated to my birthday or
at least wasn't being sent to me under
that guys well one of these is something
that actually came earlier I'm pretty
sure I forgot to mention the last time
but today into the spider-verse arrived
which oh this makes me so happy I'm
really excited to watch this again
because this has been one of those
movies that the more I've thought about
it since having seen it the more I like
it so I'm really excited to actually sit
down watch it again
ah see first of all you move saga a
which I actually have read once before
but I needed a hard copy for two reasons
one I'd like to read it again and two I
want to cover this on the podcast with
Liz so that I needed got a few things
here I got a book that was one I hadn't
heard of before called
a little big and I tell you though I am
intrigued reading the the description on
it so I'm gonna be curious about that
one
I got a notebook a fairy notebook which
makes me quite happy
that would get filled eventually and and
markers cuz yes I had markers on my wish
list because I sometimes unwind by
coloring I have I've got a Doctor Who
coloring book and a and a Harry Potter
and like a fairies one like I quite
enjoy those hi I'm new I'm new to your
channel I hope you enjoy the channel I'm
sorry I shouldn't pick on people for
typos like I'll probably end up
stumbling over my words at some point
it's as karma for that do you watch any
sports no I just I don't I never have
that okay
back to some assumptions that sense a
snippet of you came up in a fan video
that you are part of some YouTube elite
society for Doctor Who to the best of my
knowledge I'm not and actually that that
that little clip that showed up in the I
guess it was in a BBC America bumper
that I hadn't give him permission for
that yet like they'd asked and I was
getting more details on exactly what I
was what I would be signing off on the
rights to but I hadn't answered when
that bumper showed that I appeared on so
that I had some words with them over
that like I like I'm not mad I'm not
gonna sue anybody and what I said uh
yeah just I haven't said yes yet
they they then stop showing that bumper
but that uh that was enough that was an
odd experience I was super flattered to
be that they reached out to me and asked
but you know a little bit yeah less that
they didn't wait for an answer
you're excited for the Disney Fox deal
to be done I don't know if excited is
the right word I'm glad it's done I'm
tired of seeing speculation I mean I see
what's actually gonna happen I gotta go
back to the ones on the YouTube I
probably not gonna get to all these so
if anyone gave me an assumption that I
don't get to I'm very sorry for that oh
boy I was gonna wait and do this one
later but now it has come up in my field
and okay yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna deal
with this one so the assumption is
you've yet to realize that gender
dysphoria can't be a diagnosable
neurological condition if gender is
quote a social construct now I'm gonna
try and address this one without
spending too much time on it and also as
politely as I can firstly um I've never
claimed to have gender dysphoria I'm not
diagnosed with gender dysphoria and
actually if you hunt around my stuff
enough you might have picked up on the
fact that I don't have dysphoria I've
said that flat-out my sense of gender
waiver ring is not it's a positive and
not a negative and what I mean by that
is when if I'm in a more masculine frame
of mind and I start going more feminine
it's because I'm feeling a pull towards
the feminine not a rejection or push
away from the masculine so my gender
fluctuations are not due to dysphoria
that said I am still going to address
this comment more directly because I
could dismiss it out of hand on that
alone I don't want to so to address you
or argument that you can't have gender
dysphoria as something diagnoseable
while still claiming that gender is a
social construct why the hell not
I mean do you also claim that if
somebody has been medically diagnosed
with depression that they can't say that
they've had a particularly hard
mental-health day because of something
that was on the news I mean one social
ones ones medical they can't claim both
yes they can
here's a crazy idea the society in which
we live affects us the society that we
live in constructs included have an
impact on our mental health so having a
diagnosis of dysphoria and and the
concepts of gender and what it means in
a societal understanding of what is
masculine or feminine being mostly
arbitrary are not exclusionary concepts
they can both exist at the same time so
please stop trying to large entrap away
people's identities lives and and things
that they are trying to cope with there
are two simply exist in the world you
ass moving on huh
oh all right
did you like Rowling saying that
Grindelwald and Dumbledore had a
relationship that was physical I don't
care what she says anymore if it doesn't
actually show up in the films I am gonna
lose it I don't care anymore what she
says about anything that is extra to the
text it is not in the text then it's not
real as far as I as I am concerned let's
try let's try and get let's try and
light things back up again
they got serious there okay oh um
assumptions you've read a lot of comics
actually not nearly as many as you'd
think
um like I've I've only got one long box
of comics you connect it's like it's
buried under this stuff over here um
like I haven't read that many individual
issues partly because I'm more of a
trades person at this point but also
partly just cuz I can't keep up so it's
actually kind of funny it's a bit
similar to what I said about classic
Doctor Who I know a fair amount about
what is going on in comics but I don't
read a ton of them because I do kind of
keep an eye on what's going on but I
have not read nearly as many as you as
you would think
one long box you light-weight ya know
case in point as a kid you had a Lego
set I did very small one I had a space
Lego set I did I never had extensive
lego stuff just wanted to share with the
rest of your fans that Disney and
directly created the hamster dance oh
yeah because the the tune is from the
[Music]
that Disney Robin Hood yeah yeah yeah I
didn't know that my assumption is that
you
like violent macho stories like Conan or
Mad Max actually I don't mind them they
can be bad just like any kind of story
can be bad but I don't automatically
dislike them I actually love Mad Max
fury road
the original Conan was okay I'm not sure
how well it's aged but those are the
kinds of stories that like I often want
to like cuz I love the adventure of them
um I love the thrill of them sadly they
are often steeped in not great stuff so
that that is unfortunate but it's not an
inherent dislike of those stories by
their nature my assumption is that you
dislike award shows yeah the only one I
watch is the Oscars and that's only
because I go to an Oscar party for the
food and also I won the Oscar poll this
year so that was cool let's see
you don't take naps very often I don't
remember the last time I took a nap I I
think it was probably cuz I was sick
that you would love to visit the UK more
often yes accurate
I would adore getting to the UK again oh
man I haven't been there in a very long
time deal with that sorry there were
some some comments shy of those like
yeah do you want this to show you want
us to hide I'm like no you can hide that
okay this one was interesting and and
anyone like I debated covering this one
but um yeah yeah I'm just anyone who's
been to my other channel been out over
to the veer a while channel would
already know that this but I'll deal
with it here so the assumption is I
assume the hem I assume you are growing
breasts so
kind of but not on purpose so um I hang
it's probably not that noticeable in the
regular videos because most of the
usually it cuts off there so like there
is a little bit of shape going on there
at this point so I I am on hormone
adjusting meds I'm not on estrogen but I
am on anti androgens which is the
testosterone blocker I don't want to
dwell on this too long but the the idea
that and this is this is prescribed this
is not something I'm doing on my own
this is under the supervision of a my
doctor of my primary care physician so
the idea with lowering my testosterone
levels is to sort of bring my my default
setting something closer to the middle
so like if male is here in female is
here you know when with the testosterone
my default was like kind of over here in
this range whereas bringing my
testosterone level down puts my default
starting place here so it makes it no
more of an effort on my part to get to a
more feminine place versus a more
masculine as opposed to before sort of
getting into a better place with my
feminine side was more work because I
was at a masculine default now you don't
normally well I I don't know you don't
always get any breast development on
anti androgens alone usually it's only
with in conjunction with estrogen and
this is minor like I at this point I've
got an A cup but it like it is solid I
do actually
I do actually fill out an ink up at this
point so yes I I have kind of grown
breasts but it was a it was a side
effect that I knew was a possibility but
it was not a goal it's just kind of what
happened and I don't mind it let's see
for a moment there right I bet shirt was
coming up no no I don't need to get the
channel shut down you aren't actually on
hormones your titty just did that um
nope
nope yeah that did not that did not
happen on its own
do you have any asexual friends I do
have a few asexual friends I also have a
few a gender friends I've got quite a
few friends all over the all over the
place are you familiar with the sixty
soap opera dark shadows I am familiar
with it I have never watched it yeah and
not gonna touch that one do you find the
Harley Quinn character problematic ah
she can be like most comic book
characters she's been reinterpreted
enough times that some iterations are
worse than others but she sometimes she
can be yeah and and the thing is like
it's not just about what she does as a
character it also has to do with how
that is treated so like I don't think
it's automatically a problem the fact
that she has this deep affection for
somebody who is extremely abusive to her
ie the Joker but where it becomes a prod
like that in and of itself that's just a
story element where that becomes a
full-on problem is if whatever story
that's being depicted and treats it as
something that is funny or something
that is romantic that's where it becomes
problematic so like honestly some of the
early depictions of Harley on the
cartoon are problematic because it's
played for humor The Joker abuses her
and she loves him and it's played for
laughs and that's more the problem than
the idea that she's in love with her
abuser that in and of itself doesn't
have to be a problem it's all about how
it's handled and how it was treated oh
yeah oh yes um I did I saw that it
happened let me get back to that sorry I
missed a super childhood Oh spider-man
is your favorite MCU character yes that
is accurate I he had a leg up spider-man
is also my favorite superhero period so
there was a pretty good chance that
that he was going to be but yeah no you
got that I assume you aren't a fan of
PewDiePie I have no opinion on PewDiePie
I know I know a bit about like I know a
bit about him because it's hard to avoid
I've never watched him I had I have no
opinion zero um let's see let me get
back to some of these your favorite
color changes often actually my favorite
color has stayed the same since I was
five
it's dark green for the right-click
you'll try anything at least once almost
you have a generally supportive family I
have an incredibly supportive family so
yeah
assume that you like rainbows who'da who
doesn't like rainbows come on now now
your allergy to research is more due to
constraints than laziness no no even if
I had all the time and no constraints I
still wouldn't really enjoy doing
research when you love something or
someone you love them with all the
passion you have oh I try to I don't
really know how to answer that's one of
those things that's like that's that's
more for them to answer then than me I
feel like you have a favorite everything
I probably but also not off the top of
my head I have a feeling that my answer
to your favorite live depending on what
it is chain will get a different answer
do you got a pride I do I go I go to
Vermont pride every year but Vermont
pride is in September so I haven't been
to a pride event during Pride Month um
God not since I would lived in Brooklyn
holy crap so like twelve years ago maybe
whoo assumption you were positively
surprised by
Larson's performance I was positive on
her performance I wasn't that surprised
because I didn't think it looked bad
assumption your favorite x-men is
Nightcrawler mmm-hmm
here's the thing my favorite x-men
character is sometimes on the team is
sometimes the villain so I don't know
whether I can count them or not and
that's mystique so if I'm not allowed to
count mystique as an x-men member which
she has kind of been at a couple of
points then yes Assumption you don't
like cheese how dare you oh I live in
Vermont home of Cabot cheddar
I love cheese something you hate it when
people dwell more on the creators act on
what creators actors say than the actual
piece of art in question holy crap do I
ever oh geez
oh you love Ellen Page because I mean
who doesn't know I like it Ellen Page I
don't know if I love Ellen Page uh yes I
am watching Umbrella Academy I'm halfway
through it trying to finish through that
assumption you have an opinion for
everything yeah I mean unless I feel
like that like I literally have no
business having an opinion like the
reason I said I have no opinion on Pete
on PewDiePie is I have no business
having an opinion on PewDiePie as it was
Considine I'm personally offended I'm
sorry Wisconsin we have better cheese
deal with it uh I assume you were one of
the most popular nerds at whatever
smallish College in the middle of the
woods you went to um wrong on both
counts
I I went to UVM University of Vermont
which I mean you might think over Mont
actually UVM's a pretty sizable school
and no I was not especially popular I
didn't I my college experience was not
great mostly do my own fault so white
chocolate actual chocolate no white
chocolate is not actual chocolate but it
is awesome
assumption you prefer wine to beer yes
Oh God God yes hashtag cheese war you
laugh at the idea of going to the club
no I get tired at the idea of going to
the club did you watch any of Titan's
once it was out I have a review of
Titan's going up on Friday so stay tuned
uh the fact is we're literally the dairy
State don't fight me please alright look
you're entitled to your wrong opinion
I'll let it go what is your favorite
classic who episode city of death you
play D&D and you're the DM um I do play
D&D sometimes I'm not a DM III would
suck as a DM it'd be awful you prefer
champagne to wine because it's the
festive version of wine actually not
automatically depends on the wine super
excited to see your review I I hope so
it took a long time to put together so
like the the times review is like
weirdly ambitious by my standards so
we'll see how that goes let me see how
how many more of these I can cram in and
the time we've got left that you were
always dissecting and reviewing problems
with something yep yes I am you have
siblings
yes and no I have a half-sister but we
didn't grow up together so like I
technically do have a sibling but I was
effectively an only child I was raised
as an only child so depends on how you
want to parse that your enjoyment of
movies is often hindered by a need to
analyze the messages it sends not really
I'm usually able to enjoy things on a
surface level and then analyzing mess
messages usually just reinforces
whatever opinion I already have it's
pretty rare that analyzing the messages
of something actually changes my opinion
of the work either for good or for ill
because there's bad stuff with good
messaging and there's good stuff with
bad messaging assumption you can get
lost in a spiral of analyzing things
even though you should probably let it
go and get some sleep yeah yeah you like
tokine I like Hobbit Tolkien's writing
when he wasn't deliberately writing for
children is very dry I had a hard time
reading Lord of the Rings let's see
there was one that I saw Oh
as such you dressed goth or emo in high
school I probably would have if I hadn't
gone to a school with a dress code
something you don't watch comedy shows
like The Office or partisan record I
don't watch those ones specifically I do
watch Brooklyn nine-nine which is has
some of the people who did parts and
wrecks involved so I'm not completely
opposed to that kind of comedy but I I'm
not well I flat out don't like the
office and Parks and Rec I don't mind
but I don't love Lonely Island is the
best thing ever true no Weird Al is the
best thing ever lonely Ireland's pretty
good though
you use they/them pronouns I like I said
with pronouns I I tell people just to go
with whatever makes sense to them I just
don't get hung up anymore I assume
you're not that into JRPGs I'm I mean I
can't say these days cuz I'd like I
haven't played anything more current
than a ps3 generation game but I used to
really love JRPGs I mean my favorite
video game of all times Final Fantasy 6
I loved Chrono Trigger love Secret of
Mana I liked like Breath of Fire you
know so six bit era JRPGs I liked quite
a bit you don't like the office now I
don't I don't like cringe humor I I just
that's it makes me uncomfortable to
watch and it's cringy humor and I'm not
judging it I'm not saying it's bad but
it's a style of humor that I do not
enjoy watching Cthulhu is the DM of your
nightmares no I have pretty mundane I've
got a test and I didn't study nightmares
not not as inventive as one might think
uh have you seen any of crazy
ex-girlfriend yes Liz and I watched that
we've only gone through the first season
cuz it's something we watched
sporadically but actually okay random
like total non sequitur just to not I
was gonna say humble brag it ain't
humble I was um the Rachel bloom I'm
sorry yeah I think that's it who's the
starring Brice the song faces you
created crazy ex-girlfriend um I was in
a movie with her back in New York that
never got released and nobody involved
got paid for but I I actually was in a
scene with her I I have an IMDB
for that I was the maitre d in a
restaurant scene um so I I actually got
to do a scene with her and now like this
this was before she was this was even
before um you know her Ray Bradbury song
so this is going way back it was funny
too because I saw an interview she did
not that like sometime last year she had
a movie come out that I guess her her
husband directed and the interviewer
said so this is your first movie and she
said no actually I was in this little
indie thing in New York but it never got
released and we weren't paid so I don't
count it I was like hey I was in I got a
kick out of that
I got assumption gravity falls has been
on your to-do list for years and you've
yet to see it yes
assumption you can't help but search and
identify as many tropes as you can every
time you watch something actually what
while I zero went on like what did or
didn't work I'm not like uh I'm not like
let's parse everything out into its
component parts thing
have you seen Always Sunny in
Philadelphia I tried it it didn't didn't
work for me um you're somewhat
introverted but not excessively shy yeah
me kind of I talked about that a little
bit ago so I'm kind of blazing through
these I didn't want to try and get there
as many as I could um I assume you don't
have a garden to yourself but still like
seeing flowers in the park I actually do
have a garden I'm not like I'm I don't
always enjoy taking care of it but I
actually do have a garden you live
fairly near your mom due to your great
relationship that is accurate that is
very accurate you enjoyed um horror
movies not so much like I don't really
subscribe to the so bad it's good thing
for the most part that's that's pretty
rare for me
you hate ice cream like unless you've
got a lactose intolerance why would
anyone hate ice cream
I mean I'm sure somebody does I'm sorry
if I offended you bud yeah no you have a
fabulous tasting glasses well I mean you
tell me I don't know what that was
all right um how we're winded down for
time let's see Assumption your favorite
Lord of the Rings character is Sam oh
you ponder that let me see
favorite Lord of the Rings Sam yes yeah
I'll give you that one
have you ever had the chance to meet
famous LGBTQ people like say your your
Ellen's and some such no there's very
few famous people that I have run into
the the Rachel bloom is kind of the you
know the the best story that I've got I
have I have crossed paths with Denis
Leary as he was going into the New
Hampshire State liquor store which was
cool I wasn't sure it was him until I
heard him speak he said something to us
asking what he wanted him to grab for
her and I almost literally bumped into
Billy Connolly when I was living in New
York so but that's about it and and
obviously those aren't lgbtq+ style
celebrities no water this time I've got
water too but this demonstrably is not
water you didn't realize that I changed
my channel name a while ago but I used
to be Ari Rabinowitz um you're right I
probably probably didn't notice I think
largely because I always just I'm pretty
sure you're the only Ari that like comes
to the chats or shows up in comments and
whatnot so I'm pretty sure I was just
zeroing in on only theft
what hero would you call to move your
couch Superman I mean why would you call
anybody else
all right there were a few more on
Twitter oh okay I hope this one doesn't
cost me the sponsorship because this one
this was an assumption again a bit like
the executioner song one was a very
targeted one and this one came from
Radio versus the Martians currently
sponsoring a video a week what what
revelatory tragic backstory has
contributed to your visceral dislike of
salba Gemma's comic art his stuff is
exciting and dynamic and he draws the
best punches in the business is there a
way to make your heart grow three sizes
Sal no like okay I don't know what it is
with the comic-book readers my age and
older why they okay if you don't know
who salabhasana is this is his stuff and
I know it looks ok from a distance but
like really look at these faces that cuz
that's my thing with his stuff I hate
his face is their ugly as hell and like
everyone that I know that likes Albus
Emma they praise the heck out of his
punches the bus Emma punch and the guy
can do dynamic actual enough but I don't
care I'm always distracted by how ugly
the faces are I'm sorry like I I can
even see a comparison to some artist I
like like I like John Romita Jr I didn't
used to like him he grew on me but and
like I remember thinking while ramita
grew on me will boost Emma and I went
back along to someone no that's still
but ugly I hate it Oh bah ha ha people
starting to sign up bye
Congrats on winning the listener of the
year for from Professor Alan I'm
insanely jealous as you should be Kent
that actually was a lot of fun people
who don't know that's the that's the
relatively geeky podcast which I feed
back on a wash
um see I always hated when sales issues
came up in a crossover yeah yeah no I'm
right there with you see if I've got any
more here I assume you want to introduce
your feminine parents more to the
channel I don't think so um just because
I think going any more feminine than
like just this is honestly a lot of work
it's that I'm just not in the mood to do
our rotini your favorite pasta um I'm
actually partial to ziti with lines um I
I mean I like pasta in general though
yeah your good looks are due to black
magic and somebody replied to that
saying no it's TARDIS its TARDIS blue
here's the thing it depends on how you
define black and I am going to leave it
as that leave it at that so it it all
just depends on how you choose to
classify your magic I assume your
totally fabulous not always but on
occasion assumption you like breaking
bad but you're not sure about better
call Saul I haven't watched better call
Saul yet so you look younger than you
are
I don't know how if you know don't
answer but let's have some guesses
birthdays in two days if you're not
someone who knows cuz like I probably
mentioned at some point yes let's see
some guesses as to how old do you think
I look so we'll see if I look younger
than I am
beards yay or nay beards nay for me they
can work for other people let's see what
we've got 35 33 32 33 6 32 alright so
it's not 28 oh damn okay I'll take that
ha ha 42
I'm not mad Ian cuz I love the reference
um the fun part is the okay only one
setting aside the 32 and now a 79 which
is you know somebody be facetious I hope
um the highest guess is actually what
I'm turning which is the 37 ah a lot of
these worse a couple years under a lot
of 32 so yeah 37 I will be in two days
I've got oh I've gone over how long I
intended I've got I think I've only got
like one of these left to do hang on ah
I'll get there do you read Star Trek
books I have not 666
I assume you are fun to hang out with
but as a fan I don't know how that would
work with without some stalking and self
insertion into your daily life well that
escalated quickly I don't know what to
say to that but I gotta love it have you
seen Star Trek discovery I have not I
want to but I have not we want you guess
what we want you to go over an hour
I appreciate that um like I don't do by
the hour cutoff is like our people are
done maybe listening to me it's more
just like trying trying to keep myself
on a planet on a schedule
oh you're atheist no this came up
earlier I am NOT I'm turning 27 this
year
oh you child you you you sweet sweet
child
have you watched Game of Thrones I have
be doing episode by episode reviews once
that starts airing again I hope I hope
one of them isn't that you're a vegan or
have some kind of nut allergy neither of
those would be accurate so that I think
that's all I had again I might have
missed one or two like there were some
that were slightly repetitious from
others that I did skip and hopefully I
didn't accidentally skip ones that I
meant to answer but I think that'll wrap
it up what religion are you I'm not I'm
not part of any organized religion but
like I do have a certain degree of faith
agnostics probably the best way to go
except I have a Lula I have a little bit
of an idea but like nothing formalized
and I wasn't raised as anything but
atheist means you don't believe in God
and that's I mean ah see the Orval is
awesome
your assumption you're gonna end the
livestream now yeah yeah I think it's
I've gone a little over um how long I
usually do them but um we'll wrap it up
there and Nathaniel I can be your mom oh
my god I just realized well I hope
that's not too shattering for you as a
possibility but yeah we're gonna we're
gonna wrap it up there so thank you
everybody for tuning in this this was
fun and I'm it was nicely - especially
cuz NRE I actually did to vote videos to
like most of the biggest stories that
broke this week being you know the New
Avengers trailer and the James Gunn news
so you know I'm it was nice to break it
up with something else that said I may
have bit myself in the bud because this
is probably gonna end up being a little
bit redundant with the the QA that video
that I'm gonna be putting out actually
on my birthday
probably gonna end up covering a lot of
the same stuff again but you know not as
many people watch the live streams as
the video so I suppose there's always
that have a good night all